this is the most complicated nanability
in all of Hunter Hunter so I asked all
of you in a community post which
abilities you had trouble understanding
and the most overwhelmingly requested
was parallel future belonging to Fourth
Prince saratna which to put into some
perspective is an inability so
complicated that tagashi had to draw a
full-on textbook flowchart diagram to
even begin to convey it logically but
don't let all of those lines and numbers
intimidate you or even worse bore you
because this is one of my absolute
favorite abilities in the series it's a
beautiful Gem of incredible power
achieved with wildly high risk
restrictions but one thing that
complicates things right off the bat is
that surprisk is a specialist meaning
that most of the traditional rules of
nen do not apply to his abilities and
very much operate within their own
unique set of laws another factor that
often initially confuses people is that
due to serratic being a succession War
contestant he is granted a guardian
Spirit Beast as part of the rules
however right now he actually has two
Nan beasts and they tend to get a little
bit confused with each other this then
Beast here they are the horse thing with
the woman face is the actual Guardian
Spirit Beast conjured from the cedern it
has its own autonomy and its own
separate but not entirely unrelated
inability regardless forget about the
horse for now we will talk about and
explain it but for the purpose of
parallel future lenses pretend it
doesn't exist for now the Beast we're
more interested in is the second one
which I'm going to describe as having a
head shaped like a giant sperm this is
not a guardian Spirit Beast this is a
regular old nenbeast which was conjured
by ceridanic's raw Aura and raw desire
it was conjured unconsciously as well in
fact radnik has no awareness of either
of his nenboos but this second jizier
one is almost certainly the one
responsible for parallel future but
before we really get into that we need
to address some Basics because parallel
future is a three-step ability the first
of which is that saranic needs to enter
a state of zetsu and this is one of the
four basic principles of nen
specifically the suppression of Aura
which is often used to conceal your own
presence from other nen users because
wandering around town with all of your
aura leaking everywhere it's kind of
like wandering around with your pants
unzipped everyone can see see your
exposed Aura my God you indecent human
end user but not only that they can also
see just how large your aura is she yeah
what I mean very embarrassing if you
have say a micro Aura so achieving zetsu
is the equivalent of zipping up those
genes and hiding your true power from
the world however it comes at the cost
of leaving the zetsu user extremely
vulnerable because you are completely
defenseless against any kind of Nan
attack or in fact just just any kind of
attack in fact it's even worse than that
because it also leaves you vulnerable to
Accidental net exposure we saw this in
action when gone and kiloba got to the
200th floor of Heaven's Arena and were
frozen in fear after being exposed to
hisoka's hostile Ren or much more
profoundly during the Chimera antarct
when North was exposed to the potent end
of a royal guard which triggered a
complete mental breakdown encountering
that kind of Aura whilst in a state of
zetsu is said to be the equivalent of
walking around naked in a blizzard and I
go to the extremes to Define zetsu
because you really need to know just how
much of a wrist Saranac is taking by
engaging in the civil ability the fourth
Prince is left completely exposed
physically and mentally defenseless so
that's that's a pretty extreme price to
pay and what ability could possibly be
worth that cost well that takes us to
step two which is that siridnik needs to
close his eyes this is by far the most
simple step and enjoy it because it gets
a lot more complicated from here step
three is that whilst in this state
siridnik receives a vision of 10 seconds
into the future which Sarah Nick refers
to as the ephemeral 10 seconds it's a
very special 10 seconds radicus is quite
fond of them and it's important to note
that while these 10 seconds are passing
no time is actually passing in reality
all of this just happens instantly to
anyone who isn't seradnik this isn't a
New Concept to Hunter Hunter and the
most infamous figure capable of
manipulating time perception was
nefibito who was said to infinitely
compress their awareness and essentially
stop the internal sensation of time when
they were confronted with Isaac Natura
so ride Nick could be achieving
something similar stopping the internal
sensation of time but adding his own
Vision on top could also be something
completely different to do with all
sorts of wibbly wobbly timey wimey stuff
but this knowledge is exceptionally
powerful because it gives radnik the
ability to change those future events a
basic example would be one time where he
foresaw himself breaking zetsu after
hearing a bear crash so instead he
decided to change that future by
maintaining his zetsu and anticipating
the crash however the stakes immediately
get much higher because the right Nick
also foresaw his own death by a bullet
in the head administered by Theta his
bodyguard and then teacher and Source
radnik broke out of the vision to dodge
the bullet and prevent said death which
brings up an absolutely fascinating
interaction because the name of this
ability is currently parallel future
implying that things are playing out in
tandem which is where the mind-boggling
truly begins because once radnik opens
his eyes this is when the true effect of
the ability begins creating two separate
realities playing out side by side each
other for 10 seconds and after that 10
seconds they then converge back into one
which is where the mind-boggling truly
begins because once radnik opens his
eyes this is when the true effect of the
ability Begins
[Music]
by side with each other for 10 seconds
and after that 10 seconds they then
converge back into one so reality one is
what's right Nick himself Sees In The
Vision even if saranic does change his
future those around him are still going
to see the original future which is
presented to them in what may be some
form of Illusion meanwhile reality 2 is
the One exclusive to ceradnik where he
can enact whatever changes he so desires
so to use the gunshot as an example what
data saw in reality 1 was herself
shooting and killing seradnik however
after that 10 seconds was up so radnik
seemingly magically appeared behind her
because what happened in reality too is
that radnik dodged the bullet and
maneuvered himself behind Theta then
reality is 1 and 2 converged thus
leaving Theta completely and utterly
mentally screwed it's actually kind of
funny because when this happens in the
manga Theta experiences the dead
serratic illusion but at the same time
she also gets hit by Melody's illusion
so theta's just like I have no idea what
the crap just happened there and I wish
I could say that this is the end of
parallel future but there's more because
the a 10 second future site is not
actually limited to 10 seconds the
ability doesn't automatically stop after
that it stops theoretically whenever
cerionic himself wanted to stop however
engaging for more than 10 seconds comes
at a cost as after radnick has granted
the ephemeral 10 seconds he can keep
looking into the future however time
then starts moving again in reality so
for example if saradnik chose to view 11
seconds into the future then one second
would pass in reality and if he chooses
to view 12 seconds into the future then
that's 2 seconds and so on and so forth
you you know how to count theoretically
you can do this for as long as he wants
so long as he maintains that Zoom so so
long as he leaves himself vulnerable to
put this into maybe easier terms let's
say that you're watching the same movie
on two TVs however one TV is 10 seconds
ahead of the other at all times except
that movie is your life and you can turn
the future TV off at any time to alter
events as you see fit but there is still
one more complicating Factor because you
may have noticed this from the images
but the vision surrounding receives does
not come from his own first person
perspective and in a rather trippy twist
he views the parallel future from the
third person perspective and this is
where our big Jizzy nun Beast comes back
into things it's currently theorized
that parallel future is actually the
ability of this nenbeast since radnik's
Vision perspective matches up with the
actual placement of the nenbeast in
question but questions yes it brings up
so many questions like here's a big one
how can this Den Beast even exist if
saranyak is using zetsu to clarify zetsu
means that you are cutting off your aura
and leaving it contained within your
fleshy vessel as a result of this
anything that you've been powering with
your aura would deactivate which is very
much the case with Sarai Nick's Guardian
Spirit Beast the funky horsey creature
vanishes from existence when ceradic and
to zetsu because it no longer has a fuel
source to live meanwhile this second end
Beast appears to operate on an
unprecedented level of ore usage
although to be fair the exact same
problem applies to ceradnik himself how
is he using an ability without access to
his Aura but outside of basic
conjuration to my my knowledge this is
the only net ability that can be used in
a state of zetsu so even if you do
perfectly understand all of the time and
reality mechanics it still kind of makes
no sense from the nen perspective
speaking of though it's relevant to note
that saradnik despite being an ingenious
is still an amateur when it comes to
actually using zetsu he currently can't
activate it instantly which is pretty
wild because it means that once he has
mastered like the second or third basic
thing that everyone learns about nen
then he will be able to look almost
instantaneously into the future anytime
he wants now there are some unknown
factors with the ability serranic
himself still doesn't quite know exactly
how it works and one great unknown is
whether or not this Vision allows
seradnik to see Aura thus far it's only
been applied to situations with real
people and real constructs and the true
test of parallel future will be whether
or not it allows to ride Nick to see how
other people are going to use their
known abilities against him which is a
tricky conversation because surrounding
still has to master the basic principles
like gazetsu's he hasn't even touched
any of the intermediate ones like yo
meaning that he theoretically should
shouldn't be able to see any abilities
that are concealed within like say
kropica's chains for example however
there's also an argument to be made that
vision is based on the restrictions of
the Beast itself rather than seradnik's
own personal skills which brings up a
whole lot of other potential unknown
factors as promised though to touch on
the guardian Spirit Beast this is a
completely separate entity so radnik is
neither invoking control of nor sharing
in its abilities however it does rather
scarily take off to him this Beast has
an ability that triggers when a very
specific type of person lies to the
fourth Prince he goes to quote the man
himself what I hate the most is a lying
wench so look you have to meet the lying
wench condition first in pretty standard
and stuff but what happens after that is
a terrifying three-strike system the
first time a lying wench lies to
ceradnik they are scratched with the
barbed tongue of the horsey beast and at
this point there's no greater damage or
effect it really is more of a precursor
indicating that the ability itself has
begun and in the series theta's first
lie was when saradnik asked if he could
trust her to which they just said yes of
course I I say laser would never do
anything to harm you and then MB said
hmm detecting her lie immediately and
scratching their face and things
escalate rather quickly and quite
horrifically from here the second lie
was Theta claiming that The Gunshot was
part of Ceramics training and not at all
some sort of kill murder attempt but
look even siridnik knew that this was a
lie so the nenbees picking up on it was
to be expected and this time the horsey
Beast brought data to her knees and sent
her unconscious with the very ominous
warning of if you answered the prince's
next question with a lie you will no
longer be human they then had a bit of a
Trippy dream where ceradnick's head
appeared on the nenbeast asking if he
could trust her calling back to the
first lie and then went later woke up a
whole ton of her face was marked with
either a scar or some sort of lying
wench infection doesn't matter what it
is because what it is is not good and
there was a lot of confusion as to why
the nenbeast was giving Theta so many
chances with it currently being
hypothesized by the characters that a
third and final life will result in a
fate worse than death but they to be
engulfed into potentially an nbisto self
to become one of ceradnik's Pawns which
is very much in keeping with the
personality of the fourth Prince he
doesn't dispose of his wenches instead
he turns them into all sorts of
grotesque art pieces so of course the
Beast would have a similar and equally
as horrifying effect and while this is
separate from parallel future they do
work quite well as a set with parallel
future providing radnik with the truth
of the world around him and so long as
he applies the ability intelligently and
safely he cannot be fooled or taken by
surprise and it would be extraordinarily
difficult to outplay him meanwhile his
Guardian Spirit Beast provides him with
the truth of people you cannot hide your
true intentions from him and if you try
to it only goes on to make saradnik
stronger it's a very Troublesome set of
abilities to say the least serranic is
approaching dare I say an increasing
threat of flat out omniscience and with
one of if not the most complicated
inability in the series this is going to
push even a character like karapika to
his very limits